as a kid Tony Stark was one of my
biggest heroes and inspirations here was
a superhero whose real identity was
every bit as interesting as his super
heroic alter ego whose only power was
his smarts and he could solve almost any
problem by applying his super genius
intellect the Marvel Universe is
actually full of super geniuses but none
are quite like Tony Stark and we'll get
into that in a moment
the exciting thing is though that
characters almost like this really do
exist in real life
individuals who really have changed the
world with their vision in this video
I'm going to attempt to unfold some of
what makes those people unique so genius
is once described more simply as simply
having an extraordinarily high IQ the
problems with this definition though are
well documented more and more than
psychologists are converging on a notion
of genius that places greater emphasis
on creativity and eminent achievement in
fact when we attempt to post-mortem IQ
assessment which is also more than
likely how you would assess the IQ of a
fictional character such as Tony Stark
we look more examples of brilliance
through accomplishments than anything
else it is not enough then to simply be
highly skilled at subjects to put in
your 10,000 hours to be Tony Stark
levels of super genius you need to
change the game in one or more fields
with paradigm shifting ideas or
world-changing contributions
neither practicing dual n-back tests nor
using nootropics is going to help you to
accomplish this so where do you start
first we need to seek to expand our
knowledge as far as possible
creativity is said as neurologically
nothing more than the unique combination
of two existing ideas in this way the
brain can be thought of almost like an
input/output machine the more knowledge
you have in your fields of interest then
the greater chance you have of noticing
a novel connection and the more
disparate fields you introduce into that
mix the more opportunity there will be
for creativity at the same time as
discussed in my video on neuroplasticity
constantly learning keeps the brain more
plastic by encouraging production of
brain derived neurotrophic factor and
other key chemicals when did you become
an expert in thermonuclear astrophysics
last night at the same time learning
particular skills can give you a
particular set of tools and actually
help your thinking Tony Stark is able to
think like an engineer because he
studied engineering and the kind of
logical resourceful mnestheus teachers
can also be applicable to many other
areas I highly recommend learning to
program as a tool for thinking it's
something that anyone can do with
countless practical benefits and it's a
brilliant cognitive workout as Steve
Jobs says in the same way that computer
programming teaches you in a slightly
different way how to think and so i-i've
you computer science as a liberal art it
should be something that everybody
learned you know takes it takes a year
in their life one of the courses they
take is you know learning how to program
I happen to agree and likewise Elon Musk
who was consulted on how Tony Stark
should be portrayed in the movies is
known to have begun programming at a
young age coincidence I've been
programming since I was in primary
school and I think it's massively helped
the way I think my resourcefulness and
my ability to juggle complex ideas in my
brain but go beyond that to and learn
languages martial arts juggling learning
physical skills is very beneficial and
whatever else you can in future I'll be
covering accelerated learning techniques
in an in-depth video so stay tuned for
that one with more input and tools for
thinking then we now need to start
coaxing out these ideas
into unique combinations so how do we
achieve that ideation surprisingly the
worst thing you can try and do is force
an idea when we're stressed or highly
motivated even highly caffeinated we're
in a state of fight-or-flight this
raises the blood pressure and the heart
rate and it also gives us a kind of
tunnel vision
it makes us focus yes but it also
prevents us from thinking outside the
box daydreaming is not useful when we're
being chased by a lion
after all in an old video on thinking
outside the box I discussed how
cognitive biases such as functional
fixedness can block the creative process
and how any form of extrinsic stress or
even motivation makes this harder to
overcome even working towards a monetary
goal actually prevents divergent
thinking this is why engaging in menial
tasks or going for inspiration walks can
help to let those great ideas come it
engages the default mode network of
brain regions sometimes also referred to
as the imagination Network this is why
Einstein famously stumbled upon special
relativity while working at the Patent
Office and is why being present isn't
always superior to the default mode
network and letting the mind wander
right now there's a big obsession with
being in the moment but that's only
useful in certain circumstances let's
not throw the baby out with the
bathwater walking is particularly
effective at promoting creativity and
especially when surrounded by nature as
it's been shown to help invoke a sense
of good mood and calm which is conducive
to creativity allow your mind to drift
off occasionally and you may naturally
engage in what jung referred to as
active imagination Cal Newport and his
book deep work suggests another unique
form of meditation designed to
facilitate deep creative thought he
calls it productive meditation the idea
being that you dedicate some time to
simply thinking about an issue you need
to solve meditation where the idea isn't
to empty the mind but actually to fill
it this still teaches focus because
you're focusing on that idea but like I
say it demonstrates that completely
emptying the mind and being present
isn't always the optimal state I suggest
that you can also use this to practice
Big Idea thinking to work on your
creative problem-solving muscles by
challenging yourself to solve problems
come up with new ideas or navigate
hypothetical situations I call this
cognitive simulation training so while
going for a walk or just sitting quietly
ask yourself what would you
he became the prime minister or
president what great new app could you
create if you had the time and skill
simply dedicating time to creative
thoughts is actually how I've come up
with all the ideas for my most
successful apps or if you have to write
the next James Bond movie what would
happen how do you think the universe
started and if you want to become a
futurist try predicting how today's
technology is going to change the world
and how you can help with that reading
books on philosophy can also be a great
benefit this way you're practicing
thinking big and the said principle
specific adaptations to impose demands
suggest that this would be enough to
help you become much better at that kind
of thinking use it or leaves it as they
say plus we know that the brain loves
Big Idea thinking that this is
incredibly good for brain health as a
whole big idea of thinking is when you
take in ideas from disparate areas you
combine it with your rich knowledge that
you already have and you form some
generalized higher-level way of thinking
I've shown in randomised trials when you
engage in Big Idea thinking you increase
your brain at all levels of health Oh
better yet find a job that forces you to
learn and solve complex problems every
day oh and you can also use this type of
meditation to come up with contingency
plans for various outcomes Tony Stark
like Batman has a plan already devised
for every eventualities you could - like
I said though Tony Stark is quite
unlikely other Marvel super geniuses he
is removed from your Hank Pym your Bruce
banners and your Reed Richards why
because he manages to remain grounded
and cool well as cool as any fictional
comic book character can be Tony Stark
is as far removed from your
stereotypical Big Bang Theory super nerd
as it gets and I think this is a nice
break from the stereotype he is not just
a scientific genius but also charming
persuasive and a business genius and
this is what allows him to have such
influence over the Marvel Universe in
the real world being a genius is of no
use unless you're able to leverage that
intellect inspire others and affect
change regarded as one of the smartest
people in the world today in terms of
his IQ Christopher Langham has actually
worked most of his life as a bouncer but
the problem is that there really is a
noted correlation between high IQs and
social awkwardness geniuses might
actually overanalyze their responses to
questions and they might be overly
self-aware enabled
act in the moment all of this can
[ __ ] them socially so don't neglect
this crucial piece of the puzzle
practice your social skills try CBT and
cognitive restructuring see my recent
video for more develop your emotional
intelligence and make sure to keep
yourself grounded and to spend time with
a wide variety of different types of
people in his excellent TED talk Steve
Johnson also suggests that most truly
great ideas are not born from one mind
in those fabled Eureka moments but
rather tend to gestate over time and
particularly benefit from discussing
between big groups being able to work
with others means you can bounce ideas
off them and this is often when
breakthroughs happen they want to tell
the story of the Eureka moment they want
to say there I was I was standing there
and I had it all suddenly clear in my
head but in fact if you go back and look
at the historical record it turns out
that a lot of important ideas have very
long incubation periods if you want to
be highly effective at persuading and
inspiring others then work on eye
contact in particular people who've met
Steve Jobs and Bill Clinton described a
reality distortion field that they seem
to generate that made nearly everyone
want to impress them and do what they
say Tim Ferriss suggests this is
something that we can all learn and
develop simply by practicing brief eye
contact with strangers
obviously in not such a way as to creep
them out I'll leave a link to that blog
post in the description down below and I
recommend you to check it out I've also
noticed this to be the case when
watching Tom Cruise who is a hugely
charismatic and persuasive individual so
much so that the excellent YouTube
channel charisma on command describes
his charisma as being almost dangerous
fun fact
Tom Cruise was a firm favorite to play
Tony Stark before our DJ came along and
owned the role both Tom Cruise and Tony
Stark exhibit one identical trait a
supreme and total confidence in their
ability and the knowledge that there are
a hundred percent correct this might be
why Tony Stark doesn't second-guess
himself in conversation and it might be
why he seems charming rather than
awkward he's the smartest person in the
room and he knows it and he doesn't care
what others think of him while you might
not get to that point having a project a
goal or a passion an area of expertise
where you are confident can help to give
you a similar attraction confidence and
indifference to petty office politics or
social posturing it really doesn't
matter if the neighbor has a bigger TV
or if your colleague is bitching about
you when you've just built an arc
reactor in your Gary
Tony's level of egotism meanwhile makes
him persuasive and inspiring yes but of
course it also has its downsides too
this is where we can see the big flaw
and Tony Stark's character who feels
alone and solely responsible for the
fate of the entire world at times
leading sometimes to tragic mistakes so
perhaps you don't want an ego quite as
big as Tony's but confidence in what you
do is still a necessity if you want to
put your brains to good use
meanwhile keep learning keep absorbing
information as much as possible practice
using your brain to solve problems
develop your powers of persuasion and
engage in meaningful work then just
relax and let the world changing ideas
flow I hope you found this video useful
an interesting guys if you did then
please leave a like and share it around
subscribe to the channel if you haven't
already all this stuff really does help
it really does make a difference and I
massively appreciate all your support so
far comment down below and let me know
what you think I've got tons of cool new
stuff on the way the Batcave video has
actually been slightly delayed but it's
still very much on the way it's just
that I'm currently reading and rejigging
my home office so this is a good time
actually for me to be working on filming
that and once that's done I'll have it
up soon I'm also doing a video on the
myth vs. reality regarding Bruce Lee
could he really do all that awesome
stuff that he's said - I'm gonna be
doing a video on how an average person
might create a Batman esque training
routine and we've got some really cool
martial arts stuff on the way as I
teased I can't give any more information
about that right now but just stay tuned
it's gonna be really awesome I tried
some slightly different editing in this
one I'm going for a kind of a MV style I
thought it could be a bit inspiring for
those that like me think Tony Stark's
awesome I'd love to know your thoughts
on that let me know down below if you'd
like to see more of that kind of editing
so yeah thanks a ton for watching guys I
massively appreciate it and I'll see you
next time bye for now